today we'll learn about greatest country
in the world sweden you're welcome
everyone we all know sweden invented
such amazing things like floorball
where were you before floorball
floorball
greatest sport sweden invented greatest
sport
where were you before adjustable range
you're welcome
sweden where were you before old man
you're welcome sweden i don't really
know that much history about sweden so i
i thought today we're going to check out
history of sweden
how sweden became sweden first let's
check out some more fun facts
sweden has twice the population of
norway
yeah you got no chance norway
give up 5.8 billion statistically norway
shouldn't even exist
oh it's denmark oh sorry denmark sorry
sweden imports waves from norway
that's right we take your guard we're
taking norway's trash
swedish people love to recycle only one
percent waste end up in landfill
50 being recycled fortnite being
incinerated for energy
we import trash from other countries
that's how good we are at trash baby
countries
actually pay sweden to take their waste
[Laughter]
balls donald duck is more popular than
mickey mouse yeah this is actually true
i don't know why mickey mouse kind of
suck i don't know what i don't get it
dude every friday a new episode of
kellogg
which is what we call donald duck would
arrive in the mail
and it was the best i would run home
from school
frantically check my mailbox for the
next
calendar hell yeah
sometimes you would get like toys with
the subscriptions
hell yeah the best i'm just reminiscing
now sorry sweden
sweden good norway ben oh i found out
this recently
did you know that norway almost cost the
end of the world
thank you norway thank you so much the
norwegian
rocket incidents oopsie this is during
the cold war
where russia was only a few minutes from
firing nuclear weapons
which because they had detected a
missile on their radar
but which just turned out to be uh
norwegians
firing stuff in the air i don't know
what they do over there so thank you
norway
thank you so much some might say it's
russia's fault but
or america's fault no it's norway's
fault
it says here participants united states
russia and norway anyway sweden
i was such a dick in norway you're a
great norway
you don't you didn't create floor ball
but you're okay interesting and fun
facts about
sweden figures the thing i don't really
get the point of fika it
basically means like having a snack
right we used to usually have coffee or
soft like lemonade with uh keniel boule
and that's it i don't get it i don't
know why we're defining fika as a big
thing in sweden
you just have a coffee and a sweet
sweden is a monarchy
did you know huh did you know swedish
king likes to wear funny hats
he just can't stop wearing funny hats
that is not real
that is definitely real a man of culture
some might say there's too many there's
too many for this not to be a kink
no he did not wear that this is is this
a photoshop
meme this is this is a photoshop meme
[Laughter]
okay well that's a swedish tradition
thing you can't don't hate on that
that's
he just can't he can't help himself he
can't
help himself i also found out there's a
sweden in japan
called sweden hills sweden hirusu
in hokkaido i would love to visit this
one day look at this
in japan dude wester what
they even do our traditions that is so
weird
oh mid-summer that would be lit sweden
hills
also holds the midsummer festival
what a bunch of swede weebs get over it
nerds even the architect oh my god that
is
nuts some swedish words that you might
appreciate apparently there are some
words
that you can't really what the hell is
this really
oh great we made up a word for a new tax
congratulations sweden
it's swedish oh it's the longest word in
sweden okay
lagom is such a typical swedish word
because it means not too little not too
much like just about right
and everyone loves to use it because
it's so typically swedish because we're
just like uh
in-betweeners and you say it la gum
no you don't what the [ __ ] time optimus
is that unique for sweden i didn't know
that i also hate that word because
people that use that when they're late
they're like oh i'm just a time optimist
bruh shut up you don't know how to plan
ahead that is not an excuse
blow weather never heard blow weather
it means it's windy congratulations
sweden
now you just that's it no
shut up i want unique ones
untranslatable thank you
no plan what vasca
is a horrible word that no one needs to
know about holla
oh god why is this a word sweden is so
[ __ ] weird
it means dab the end of your peepee on
something
i'm not clicking on that i'm not
clicking on that but now i have to click
on
no i'm not doing that it's basically
sexual assault and that
it's so strange to me how sweden has
made this into
like what the [ __ ] no that means gurgle
that means gargle yeah i can translate
that for you idiots
oh we have a word to close your eyes and
you guys don't have that
blunder yeah shut your eyes blue that's
weird i never thought of that
oh and we have a verb for uh snuggle up
which is misa
netflix and musa i guess would be the
shell i guess
yeah all right some fun uh facts about
swedish history
i really appreciate this one king carl
the 13th
let's have a look at this dude he liked
to doodle penis over his
private diaries when he was
37 dude come on
man come on you're the king
i bet he sat there like
what can i say i come from a land of
culture
why is that a fact i want to see them i
want to judge his drawings
oh hell yeah he gave them legs and
skirts
let's go no
it's leonardo da vinci oh you freaky
italians you're so
weird italian it's dummy we would never
do that
oh this is a kind of cool thing you can
actually visit this
we built a ship that was so lavish and
so luxury i'm not sure if that was the
reason but it seemed more of a
a lesson an allegory or something that
it sank it never left the harbor because
it just sank right away it was too heavy
we're like hey we're gonna build the
most badass ship ah
damn it it has to float what
you can visit this if you go to
stockholm it's actually pretty cool
actually i don't know if it's cool i
went when i was like five but it was
cool then so
oh yeah and we used to have a frenchman
as a king
i remember this in history class because
he kept complaining how cold it was
fool it's so cold he he
should we try it what the [ __ ] is cold
should we die for eid
that she's sweet
did he do anything good probably not
disgrace
yeah yeah what the [ __ ] did he get in
there by the way
sorry how did that happen
uh oh nice so he was found
on his deathbed to have a tattoo that
read death to kings
all right i don't know that we you may
have heard about the bloodbath of
france or spawns or smiles we have
our own bloodbath okay you're not so
special
that's nothing really interesting about
it i look into it
oh yeah so the term stockholm syndrome
is based on a real
kidnapping event where the bank
employees were held hot sledge for six
days
the hostages became emotionally attached
to their captor and even defended them
after they were freed so that's so
swedish isn't it
he's a good guy he's a good guy he can
go he's okay
i like him we of course had the glory
days
of vikings that was a while ago i think
we need to
let that go i don't think we can claim
vikings anymore
so sweden was established a hundred
years after the vikings
interesting then we had the union of
kalimar which was like a mix of denmark
and nook
then everything was [ __ ] then we had
stock on bloodbath
and then this [ __ ] came up and
was like
you know what i'mma steer [ __ ] together
this is our first king
father of sweden gustavos huh look at
this dude
look at this dude with the tights hell
yeah
damn it's really cool seeing this stuff
uh okay so gustavosa came in
and he took away the power from the
church so he
he gave all the money to the the state
and wanted to strengthen the economy of
sweden
as far as i understand and sweden grow
very very rich and very very strong we
mined
uh copper i think yeah the swedish
empire had the greatest most numerous
copper mines in europe
so we grew very rich but we didn't have
many people living there
but then swedes decided babies we make
so many goddamn babies we make army of
babies
more babies and once we said we have
enough babies said more babies
this is the greatest summary of sweden
history and then gustav
ardolf denandre came in he's like all
right this is cool we got money
more babies we need more babies
[Laughter]
so this this leads to a kind of
controversial subject which is the
the swedish great power which kind of
blows my mind i
obviously know about in history but i
didn't realize just how
how vast it was so this is a great power
era of sweden we went to war
with everyone and if you think sweden
bad for doing that
everyone went to war with everyone in
this time okay
you bad two then but yeah we i don't
know we probably didn't have to do that
i don't know
starbucks stayed in hell yeah look at
this
this is the map what the [ __ ] is this we
had like that germany or poland or
is that amsterdam finland we didn't have
norway then
what was norway then we just caught
norway in half
wow
that's funny i don't i know so little
i'm trying to remember
i remember the story in history class
where like all our armies were here
and then we were attacked here somewhere
and there was this epic story how
they wrote all the or maybe here i don't
know they rode them over the eyes
all the armies with the horses the
gallop they were like you know what nah
we take shortcut bang so we defeated
russia
we defeated finland which wasn't even a
thing
estonia that's ours lithuania that's
ours
sweden could have been so great sweden
great
but was great with so many like lavish
artwork
well i don't know about that but that's
napoleon from this era of sweden
all the wars and this is in 1629.
he was 17 when he got the throne the
king of sweden
yeah back back in the day now we have
democracy i'm joking
back in the day sweden ruled by very
good kings
or at least they were smart good at war
17 dude you read about sun tzu yin heard
about
carl gustav then under aldo yeah we did
go against poland
sorry poland oh i remember this school
this guy
was the end of it all good starting to
call
uh calling in a good stuff look at this
dude he made peace huh this face of
peace
joking but for real though come on he
looks like the villain from pocahontas
you can't tell me i'm wrong okay i
remember this
there's this argument that it was
cheaper for us to go to war
than to have peace and that's part of
the reason why we went out
and [ __ ] about it was cheaper to
finish a war than to start one
since we had so many officers and
i guess soldiers that want to get paid
it was better to
yeah finish what we started kind of so
it just kept going
and norway's of course or want us to
seal
the deal on us again
when they killed our king called and
told that oh the legendary photo
uh the picture he fell in norway those
[ __ ]
norways man i've had enough of these
we can never defeat those standards
what did we do huh we didn't have enough
artillery
ah god damn it if we only had enough
artillery oh and the eyes wasn't
cr strong enough we couldn't do the eyes
move again damn it
uh if only the ice was stronger damn you
norway in your weak eyes
we had more people too god damn it this
is [ __ ]
i don't believe this this is full of
slander there's no way we lost again
we even had some colonies which kind of
blew my mind i had no idea about this
we had an anthem can i listen to it
never heard this so in the 17th century
the swedish empire reached its greatest
territorial
event yeah we even traded colonies
to bypass french english merchants that
was our fortress
well no wonder we lost what the [ __ ] is
this it's so tiny dude that's a tiny
fortress
that's an ant fortress we even have
places in africa
cape coast in ghana why why
oh no oh no sweden
no i thought we were clean of that
damnit
well no wonder i didn't know about it no
one's gonna tell us about that
why why did we go there some guy in
swimming is like you know what
there we're going there
[Laughter]
i don't understand communism or whatever
it's just kind of interesting that that
was
how it was back in the day for a lot of
countries okay sweden
um it's made in sweden but now when you
have your next speaker
think of um what is this video at this
point
trying to end it on a nice way i can't
get past this
hey look we had the coins that's cool
damn
all right see you tomorrow new video bye
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use
any item in your inventory and make
memes inside tuber simulator
add some of our patented stickers in
there stickers our emotions
memes our emotions express your emotions
with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows maybe i'll review your
memes the greatest honor of all time
full circle baby download it make a meme
[Music]
we need subtitles on this